m
[Musique]
vous
mon mari et moi nous comptons partir à
la retraite vers la fin de l'année et
pour l'instant nous n'avons aucun
remplaçant en vue il ya eu beaucoup de
visites et pour l'instant aucun
aboutissement positif
alors c'est pour nous très difficile de
partir en sachant qu'on va laisser
beaucoup de gens dans la demande mais il
arrive un moment où on ne peut plus
continuer quoi
je
évidemment
une cassure
ça quelqu'un
ça joue ça s'en vient
nantes m
pour les passants
[Musique]
quelquefois ça nous est même arrivé
d'appeler le 15 on enlève ce conseil
voilà on n'est jamais sûr de pouvoir a
rendez vous voilà puis nous on vieillit
puis la flèche devant le juge elle a une
moyenne d'âge pas très jeunes n'ont plus
de lucas black ont besoin aussi je pense
[Applaudissements]
millions est demandée
[Musique]
pour sa part monsieur le maire bonjour
sur le principe je ne suis pas contre de
venir à certaines conditions 1 je venais
prime de délocalisation et
d'installation de un logement de
fonction pendant deux ans 3 une voiture
de fonction
4 un terrain ne permettant d'envisager
une construction top c est ce qu on doit
continuer ou collectivités cette
surenchère moi je moi ma réponse a été
fait c'est non et que la réponse je n'ai
pas fait ce médecin c'est pas possible
[Musique]